Legacy sequels are always a risky
proposition but Creed defied the odds
and launched a whole new franchise from
where the rocky films left off the film
stars Michael B Jordan as Adonis Creed
son of Apollo Creed whom Carl Weathers
played in several movies weathers wasn't
in any of the Creed movies but his
presence could be felt it only makes
sense that Jordan would honor the man
whose footsteps he walks in on his
Instagram stories Jordan posted a
picture of weathers along with the
statement we lost a legend weathers may
not have appeared alongside Jord in the
Creed films but he loved what the actor
did with the character shortly after the
release of the first Creed movie
weathers posted on X formerly known as
Twitter Michael B Jordan you did well
for the Creed name congrats on a great
job my friend may your success continue